des policiers anti émeute y charge la
cool qui lancent des grenades
lacrymogènes ou tire des balles de
caoutchouc sur les manifestants
des images qui se répètent semaine après
semaine en france jusqu'à en devenir
reste banal
we7 mais pour frank d'idron c'est tout
sauf anodin car sa vie a chaviré le 1er
décembre dernier tout en haut des champs
elysées toujours interphone à l'oreille
le tourner la tête et l' agence une
balade lbd40 est sûre le choc j'ai
poussé un cri c'était sa première
manifestation
il s'est retrouvé au milieu de nuages de
gaz lacrymogènes
encerclés par les policiers puis touché
en pleine tête par une balle de
caoutchouc et au moment du choc
j'ai volé en fait je suis tombé en
arrière et sa minute après tordu de
douleur je pouvais plus super mal
le jeune homme de 20 ans a perdu son
oeil droit a eu le crâne fracturé alors
dans l'ordi je peux plus me regarder
dans un miroir
prochain défi urgent plus personne on
sera pris entre hambourg 1 tonio
barbetta lui a été blessé une semaine
plus tôt le pied transpercé par un éclat
de grenade une grosse détonation un gros
flash de lumière et donc suite à ça
effectivement une grosse sensation de
brûlure à mon pied
effectivement je pouvais plus poser mon
pied des blessures devenu tellement
nombreuses que ce journaliste
indépendant a entrepris de les recenser
de les documenter et devez signaler
systématiquement aux autorités à ce jour
david dufresne enquêté sur plus de 364
de blessures graves comme celle
d'antonio et de franck on sait il est
révolté je considère que la france pays
des droits de l'homme est en dessous de
tout c'est à dire que la france la
république française se déshonore depuis
plus de deux mois a transformé le
maintien de l'ordre
en répression le journaliste comme
beaucoup de médecins critiquent surtout
l'emploi massif des lanceurs de balles
de défense responsable de la plupart des
glisses haut de gamme
avec 9 minutes de sentir en 2010 on voit
bien qu'on est passé d'une arme de
dernier recours pour s'extraire d'une
situation difficile à une arme d'attac
et antonio mais il est aujourd'hui
activement pour l'interdiction de ces
armes
une cause pour laquelle ils marcheront à
nouveau samedi aux côtés d'autres
blessés pour la première fois depuis
leur traumatisme pour ne plus être des
statistiques anonymes des victimes
invisibles et si jean françois bélanger
radio-canada paris